the Gerhard Hoffman theater is her
artistic home Christiana Hoffman is
responsible for making sure that
gurlitt's in eastern Germany has its own
theatrical spectacle every year hello
guten tag is finicky Anna hello my name
is Christiana Hoffman and I've lived in
gurlitt's since i was a child i work at
the girl it's theater and I'm the
artistic director of the International
Street Theatre Festival the event
continues for three days
it's just one of the tourist attractions
in the town that's located near the
Polish border crystianna's first trip
for visitors is to see the baroque house
it was built in the early 18th century
for the trader Johann Christian Thomas
now it belongs to the girl its cultural
history museum when wasn't these as how
is gain assist you have to see the
interior it's totally eclectic there's a
wonderful courtyard and a beautiful
library as many very old books and you
can see how people lived in the Baroque
era how rich they were I like to walk
around here and imagine i'm wearing a
lovely dress in the boro cage last night
I not get the mohawk
the library is like a treasure chest
it's clear that it belonged to one of
the great intellectual societies of
Central Europe one of its prized
possessions is a book by the geographer
Ferdinand von Richtofen charting his
research crystianna's second tip is to
visit a bridge that starts in Germany
and ends in Poland the bridge in the old
town was blown up during the Second
World War but it was rebuilt in 2004 it
crosses the river NASA between Berlitz
and Germany Ansgar zealots in Poland
softly yeah I understand it used to be
one town and now it's a divided town the
old town bridge connects the tomb I like
being here because we can experience the
street theatre festival on both sides
people from gurlitt's can go to Poland
and the Polish residents can come to see
the artists in Germany kalanchoe non-hd
guns often so I often stand here in the
summer and look at the river I'm just
happy this bridge is here look at goods
the bridge is a symbol of a Europe
without borders just a few minutes walk
away is the restaurant distill it
okay fine and of course there's a local
favorite on the menu a traditional dish
called salesian heaven she lasers with
female Isis in the salesian heaven is a
really tasty dish gurlitt's used to be a
part of Silesia and this food is typical
because it combines sweet baked fruit
with a piece of cooked or smoked pork
along with classic salesian dumplings it
warms your heart and it really tastes
good too the man [ __ ] mountains have
some respect fo compensatory Christiana
goes underground to give us her next tip
for a visit to gurlitt's directly under
the restaurant there's an old Jewish
ritual bath used up to the 15th century
the water's cold between six and ten
degrees Celsius it was used for
cleansing worshipers before they entered
the temple
that's good to survive develop the
Jewish bath and gurlitt's is special
there aren't many of these left in
Germany gurlitt says connection with
history is what this local resident
finds really special about her hometown